When you were in a small class, i.e.
in seventh or eighth class,
you must have witnessed
or even felt it with the children, maybe some teacher
asked you to come forward and explain to everyone else what
we have just done.  Have you read or witnessed this?
Yes and No in the chat box. If a
teacher tells you that in tomorrow's class
you have to study this topic for example
and you have to teach this same topic to the whole class,
if you have experienced the thing.
So you might have experienced that when you were
told that you have to teach the entire class,
no matter how much knowledge you had on that topic,
you gained access to that knowledge and
you studied that topic in great detail
so that you could teach all the other children.  Be able to explain
and while you were explaining, your own
understanding regarding that topic gets doubled.
Yes and No in the chat box.